au 1er décembre dernier les travaux de
la partie basse de la toiture de
l'église sont lancés l'objectif est de
remplacer les tuiles par dollar d'oise
pour une meilleure étanchéité
une semaine après tout s'arrête les
ouvriers découvrent des anomalies sur la
partie haute de l'église la charpente se
dissocie par endroits ce qui affaiblit
tout l'édifice
c'est une grosse surprise que là on est
sur un budget qui fait trois fois
supérieur à celui que nous avions estimé
sur la partie basse la commune a donc
décidé de réaliser la première partie
des travaux prévus et pour lesquels elle
possède le budget en parallèle elle
lance un appel d'offres auprès de
différents architectes afin d'échelonner
la future réfection de la charpente
sécurisation d'abord et puis après on
envisagera selon les dotations via des
subventions s'ils sont importantes je
pense qu'on réalisera les travaux
complets et si par contre les
subventions sont relativement faibles
là on envisagera seulement de sécuriser
l'édifice pour permettre au moins son
utilisation sens sans sa fermeture
un toit qui fuit et des murs qui se
fissure pour les habitants c'est la
désolation sur suis malade en ce moment
oui ça m'inquiète
oui parce que où est ce que l'on freine
aux offices plus d'un terme on vit là sa
marque loin puis on peut pas quand même
laissé un bâtiment à l'abandon
c'est quand même un patrimoine que tous
les habitants sont très très fier de
l'avoir il y a un an une association
s'étaient montés afin d'aider la commune
a financé les premiers travaux
aujourd'hui elle va devoir triplé ses
efforts
c'est essentiel c'est plus qu'important
imaginez délices des noms déjà pris
village le 5 mars prochain concert sera
donné dans l'église afin de récolter des
fonds